MALE SPEAKER: Hi, folks.
Welcome to our
panel, "Breakthroughs
in Machine Learning."
we've been talking a lot
about Google's
long-term vision for AI
and all the work
we've been doing
for the past decade and a
half on machine learning.
And this is important because
our users and your users
expect the impossible.
They want technology
that they can
talk to naturally just the way
you would talk to a person.
Obviously, not possible
today, but we're
moving in that direction.
And I think a point
that often gets missed
is that Google
isn't just working
on incremental improvements
to products using known
machine learning techniques.
We actually have teams
doing fundamental work
on improving the state of
the art in machine learning.
And they're working right
here in Mountain View
and in our locations
around the world.
So you're going to hear
from some of these folks.
I think if you're also getting
your hands into the deep thick
of things, and you're
working with TensorFlow,
you're working on
machine learning models,
you can maybe learn
something from the war
stories, the challenges that
you hear they've gone through.
If you're a developer
who just wants
to use what they've packaged up
in the cloud machine learning
APIs that we offer, you
can get a good sense
of which things are working
well and how you might
use these in your products.
So I hope you enjoy it.
We're going to start
with Francoise.
[APPLAUSE]
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: Hi.
So my name is Francoise.
I work on speech recognition.
And I joined Google
about 10 years ago.
And it may be hard to remember,
but 10 years ago, there
was no iPhone.
There was no Android.
So speech recognition was
used mostly in call centers.
And it was this annoying thing.
It wasn't a lot of fun.
So I came to Google
with two goals in mind.
The first one was to make speech
recognition fun and useful.
And the second one was to
make it work really well
for everybody on the Earth.
So with that, we're now 10
years later and about 20%,
almost 20%, of the queries
that come into Android phones
are made by voice.
So we take that
as a real success.
And, of course, we just
released the Cloud Speech API
that allows all of you to
develop more fun products
with speech recognition.
We currently cover
about 80 languages
and locales which could reach
to about 4 billion people.
And you could ask me, why did
it take 10 years to get there?
After all, speech recognition
should be very easy.
One-year-olds can do
speech recognition,
and a few years later, they will
be able to transcribe it, too.
But if you look at
the different users
and the different scenarios,
they have different needs.
And they speak differently.
So I was hoping to
play a few sound bites.
Can someone there
click on the video?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-When is stinger season
in the Great Barrier Reef?
-[SPEAKING HUNGARIAN]
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: So this
person is speaking Hungarian.
-What noise does
an elephant make?
[END PLAYBACK]
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: So,
I mean, seriously, this
is the type of data
that we should expect.
And we want to serve these
users no matter who they are.
So we do the best we can,
but sometimes, obviously, we
get it wrong.
And this is a case that was
recently reported to us.
A user speaking Spanish
said "llama a Juan."
They wanted to
call their friends.
But were recognized "Yamaha
Juan" as if this person wanted
to buy a piano or something.
The next one is an example--
you might have guessed by now,
I'm a French speaker.
So I try my products in French.
And a couple of
years ago when I said
to the Recognizer, [FRENCH],
I would get this result.
It sounds the same,
but the spelling
is completely butchered.
And then I came across
this example in Korean.
If you look at
the strings, we're
actually getting every single
Hangul, every single character
right, but the white spaces
are not at the right space.
And that means something
very different,
as you can see from
the translation.
So we make mistakes.
But this is speech recognition.
Speech recognition
is machine learning.
Machine learning
can fix everything.
So we can get it right.
But before we go more
into how we get it right,
I want to give you just a
very high level look at how
speech recognition works.
So you have a speech waveform
that comes into the system.
And you're trying to get
a sentence out of it.
So in the system,
there are three models.
There's an acoustic
model that takes snippets
of that soundtrack and
tries to find distribution
of probability over phonemes,
the individual sounds
of a language.
Then there's a
pronunciation model
that takes those phonemes
and makes words out of them.
And then there's a language
model that strings words
together with probabilities.
If you want to see
this is an equation,
it's essentially
saying that we're
trying to find the
word sequence that
has the highest probability
given the acoustic observation.
And with a little
bit of math, you
can decompose that into
three probabilities,
a product of those
three, which correspond
to the different models.
So all this to say, this
is a statistical model.
There are three
different models.
Everything in there
is statistical
and can be learned from data.
And the first one,
the acoustic model,
is something I want to talk a
little bit more about because
for a long time, for
many decades, actually,
we were using a technology
called Gaussian Mixture Models,
which served the community
of speech recognition
very well for a long time.
But in 2012, we changed
that to neural networks.
And it took us a
while to get there
because those neural
networks take time to train.
They're big.
If you want to get the right
latency characteristics out
of the system, you
have to optimize a lot.
But eventually we got there.
And we get huge
accuracy improvements
out of switching
to neural networks.
But in addition to that,
the thing that's interesting
is that it restarted a
revolution in the field.
By having that
infrastructure in place,
we started innovating
the type of architectures
of the actual structure of the
neural networks and the way
we're using them.
And year after year, and I
would say month after month,
we came out with
new structures that
were always more powerful
than the previous generation.
So we went from
deep neural networks
to recurrent neural
networks with LSTM.
From there, we added
convolutional layers
that allow us to better deal
with noise and reverberences
in this room.
And from there to a
connectionist temporal
classification,
CTC, which I will
show a little bit more about.
These types of improvement
in the structures
result in improvements
in quality.
So over 2015, over all
the different groups
of languages that
we cover, we've
had accuracy improvements.
And going back to
CTC, like I said,
the CTC has allowed
us to decrease
the latency of our speech
Recognizer quite a bit.
And that means that when you're
speaking to your Recognizer,
you get your
response much faster
and gives you that snappiness
that feels comfortable.
Now, of course, sometimes
things are complicated.
And we went through
several lessons in our life
as a group doing speech
recognition at Google.
But for you to really
appreciate those lessons,
I want to give you
just a tiny bit
more about how the
speech Recognizer works.
We're using, like I said, a lot
of data to train our models.
And there are
different sources that
go into training those models.
The models go into
the Recognizer.
And we're using the data that
comes out of the Recognizer
to feed back into the
models because that's
data that's very well matched
to what we're trying to do.
The problem is that
that data occasionally
has typos, various problems.
Data is never clean.
And that caused the
issues that we've seen.
So one day in Korean, we
started seeing this word, keu-a,
appearing all over the place
in our Recognizer outputs.
And we didn't quite
understand why.
So we started analyzing.
And we realized that it was
the voices of little kids.
It's people making
voice queries,
but there are kids
in the background.
And those little
voices-- you know,
high-pitched words--
the Recognizer didn't
know what to do with it.
So it found a word
that was vowel-heavy,
like [INAUDIBLE] and it
tried to pick that word.
And it started recognizing
it all over the place.
And because of the feedback
loop I was showing you,
it just fed back into the
system and grew and grew.
But before we could fix
it in British English,
we started seeing
this word, kdkdkd.
Now can one of you guess
where that one is coming from?
Someone said it.
The train.
Subway.
So it's people using their phone
on the train on the subway.
[SUBWAY SOUND]
And the Recognizer
didn't know what to do,
and output something.
And then the last one, it's
maybe a little embarrassing,
but it was this word. [LAUGHTER]
And when we looked more
into it, what was happening
is people taking their phone
and they're [DEEP BREATH].
And then they talk.
Take a deep breath.
So you have that blow of air.
And then it goes quickly
on the vowel and the click,
and that's what the
Recognizer found.
So as soon as I became
aware of that one,
I knew that we had to
do something about it.
And we fix these
type of problems
by actually putting more human
knowledge into our systems.
We started using more linguists,
using more human resources
to try to format the data
well and to transcribe
the data correctly.
And we built very sophisticated
guidelines to get our data
transcribed correctly
so that we could
leverage that human knowledge.
With just 3 million
annotated waveforms,
we can train our
acoustic models,
learn new pronunciations
from the data,
augment the size of our
language modeling training set.
And all that gives
you improvements.
But now, with 3
million waveforms,
we said, well, we can
do a lot of things.
How about 30 million?
So we just embarked
into an effort
to transcribe 33,000
hours of human speech.
It takes 600 people to do that
in a reasonable time frame.
But with this data,
we're dreaming
about new architectures,
more complicated, more tight
that we can use.
And we think that
with that maybe
we can solve the big dream
of speech recognition,
of really making it work
for every person on Earth.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I pass it to Andrew, who will
talk about graphs and pumpkins.
ANDREW TOMKINS:
Thanks, Francoise.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Andrew.
So this is the usual picture
you have of machine learning.
We have some reds.
We have some blues.
We'd like to try to learn
a model that will separate
the reds from the blues.
And then when new input comes
along, we'll apply our model.
And we'll guess whether
it's a red or a blue.
So that is not the
framework that we're
going to talk about today.
Today, we're going to
talk about something
a little bit different
for the next 10 minutes.
So here, here's me.
I'm there alone solo.
And you have to guess what
it is that I like to do.
So from the data, it's
very hard to guess.
Maybe hats are my thing.
There's not much
more that you can
get from the representation.
Maybe you'd gather
some features,
and maybe generate a training
set, learn some models,
and then try to predict what
it is that I like to do.
But we're going to talk
about another approach.
We're going to talk
about what could I
do if I understood not just
this data object alone,
but if I could put it into
context of its neighborhood
within my data set.
And so we'll add relationships
to other pieces of data.
In this case, it's my kids.
And now it's possible
to draw some inferences,
like, maybe what I like
to do is to go trick
or treating with my kids.
And so with that intuition,
that rather than operating
in isolation to classify
each data object,
we should actually make
use of the relationships
between different
data points, even data
points that we don't
completely understand.
We would like to see how far
we can go with that idea.
And so we have a piece of
infrastructure at Google
called Expander, which is
designed to do exactly this.
So this is a
large-scale platform
which is intended to
make use of connections
that we have between
data objects.
So let me give you an example.
Clearly, I like to
go trick or treating.
So it would be very helpful
if I could recognize pumpkins.
So we actually have this great
image understanding system
at Google.
And this is how it works.
It's given a bunch of images.
And they have training
labels on them.
And then it learns,
deep network,
which will be able to
recognize new images
and recognize objects
and images in the future.
And so now we hand it the
rest of the corpus, which
has no labels.
And we apply these models.
And we get our labels.
So looking at this
data, you could
ask, just how good
are the labels
that we're starting with?
And they're pretty good,
but they're not great.
So one of those is a
pumpkin, the one on the left.
The one on the right
is pumpkin soup.
And, as you can imagine, if you
were a neural network, which
you are, it would be pretty
hard to be fed that and told
to learn a representation
of pumpkins,
and be given these
confusing inputs.
So what I'm going to
tell you about first
is a hybrid system that
uses graph-based learning
and connections in order to
figure out the right training
data, and then on top of that,
apply its deep network learning
to figure out the right model.
So how would we do that?
Well, we actually do have
connections between these data
objects.
So between each of
these pixel arrays,
we've been able to
learn embeddings,
which capture the semantic
similarity of two images.
What is the likelihood
that these two images
have the same object in them?
So we can use those edges.
You can see on the left, we
could propagate the information
at the top of the
graph that says
we have things we know to be
pumpkins, through those edges,
and confirm our
initial intuition
that the thing in the
bottom was a pumpkin.
But when we look at the
right-hand side of the graph,
we can do the same thing.
We can propagate a couple of
instances of known not pumpkins
through the graph
to help us conclude
that our label on the
pumpkin soup is questionable.
Maybe we ought to rethink it.
So we can use this approach
to remove about 40%
of the training data that
initially we were using
to learn image classifiers.
And by removing that
data, we actually
got a 9% lift in our metrics
on image classification,
which improves what we can do
for Google Photos and Google
Search.
So from there, let's take
a look at how this works.
So this is the one equation
form of graph propagation.
What we're trying
to do is write down
a penalty function that
tells us how well we're
doing with respect to
the neighborhoods that
are in my data.
And so you can see, there's
a term-- lu minus lv--
which says how far apart
are the labels of nodes u
and v in the data.
And I will weight that by the
strength of the connection
between them, wuv.
And I'll add it up
over my entire dataset.
That's the penalty that says
how far away I am from properly
respecting the semantics
of the edges that I have,
the similarity information.
And then I'll try
to minimize that.
It's actually quite
easy to minimize that.
The equation at the bottom
shows that if what I do
is, for each of my
data objects, I take
a look at its neighborhood.
I use the labels that I have
for the neighbors in order
to update my label.
I do that for
everything in the graph.
And then I do it
again and again.
Information walks
through the graph.
And it converges provably
to the optimal assignment
for that cost function.
And so from that
starting point, you
can now layer in a
lot of complexity
and additional features
into the system.
So that's the algorithmic side.
But there's also a system
side here because what
we would like to do in order to
build these systems is operate
at the scale of billions
of different data objects
simultaneously.
And the label spaces
that we might apply
could actually have billions
of distinct labels as well.
And we'd like to
do this on graphs
so the penalties
that we're measuring
are measured over trillions of
edges, trillions of connections
between the objects.
So that's what we've
built in order to make
use of these techniques.
Now that we have these tools.
Let me give you a couple
of other examples.
So you heard in the
keynote about SmartReply
in the context of
messaging apps.
And I hope people
have had the chance
to try it out in the
context of Inbox right now.
Here, the vertices of this
graph are possible responses
that you might be able to send.
And the edges
represent similarity.
So it could come from maybe
a distributional similarity
to say these responses are
used in the same context.
Or it could come from
lexical similarity, say,
they have the same words.
Or similarity based
on word embeddings.
When I've got the graph, I
can now run Expander in order
to generate clusters.
And that will tell me
about similar phrases
that have the same meaning.
The personalization
features that
were alluded to in
the keynote can then
choose an appropriate
choice here
for the particular
user in their context.
And the understanding of
those different clusters
can be used to make sure that
we offer diverse choices so
that we're not
just picking three
ways of saying the same thing.
So that's great for English.
We can do the same thing
in other languages as well.
So this is an example of just
specifically for responses
that are greetings.
So in English, maybe I can
say "Hi!" "How's things?"
"What's up?"
And we have connections
between those like the ones
that we talked about
on the last slide.
But in French, I
might say [FRENCH].
And I can start to
build connections
from the French variant to
the English variant using
the models that power
Google Translation.
Maybe "How's things?" and
[NON-ENGLISH] can be connected
together based on
translate edges.
And now I can start to
flow semantic meaning
across a multilingual graph.
And that would allow us to
build data structures that
could then power features like
SmartReply in other languages
like Portuguese, Indonesian,
Spanish, even English.
Let's do one more,
one more example,
now in the space
of search queries.
So of course, I'm interested
in trick or treating.
I'd like to tell my kids
some stories about Halloween.
So I'll go to Google
and ask some questions.
My hope is that Google
will be able to give me
this featured snippet
back that will
answer my question directly.
So we have that capability.
We would love to be able
to expand the coverage
and respond to more
questions in that way.
So this is a graph whose
vertices are queries.
And the edges represent
the likelihood
that two queries
would be answered
by the same
information response.
And I can now flow
information through that graph
in order to improve
the coverage.
You can see that the stronger
edges, the ones that are solid,
are places where I'm more
confident about the meeting.
The dotted edges
might represent things
that have some drift to them.
So I have to be very
careful about exactly how I
do the propagation.
But having done that, we're
able to automatically discover
semantically equivalent
questions for more
than a billion
queries in Search.
So let me wrap up
now just by saying
that we've been using
machine learning
on graphs to understand
natural language,
to understand
queries, to understand
images and other media objects.
And we also-- you probably heard
in the keynote about PhotoReply
where we can actually recommend
responses to images just built
on the same technology.
And we can use the
same techniques
in order to generate concise
models that can actually
be applied in Android
Wear on a device
in order to do things
like recommending
an appropriate response
as we saw in the keynote
on Wednesday.
So with that, we found
a lot of great impact
from graph-based learning,
especially in scenarios
where you have a lot of data.
Labels are expensive, but
you understand something
about the connections
between your data objects.
So with that, let me pass to
Maya to talk about Glassbox.
[APPLAUSE]
MAYA GUPTA: Great.
So Andy was just talking
about questions and answers
and doing that automatically.
We're going to do that
non-automatically for you right
here in about 10, 15 minutes.
So if you guys have some
questions that you're
thinking of, we'll
have you come up
to the mics in about 10 minutes.
But first I'm going to talk
about Glassbox learning.
Sometimes people complain
that machine learning
fills a little black box.
And so our team is sort
of dedicated to making
it a little more transparent.
And as Francoise
said earlier, it's
important to get the human
knowledge into the machine
learning.
We don't just want to
pour a lot of examples in
and see what happens.
Sometimes we know
a little better.
So let me start with a story.
About two years
ago, we were working
on a video recommendation
system using machine learning.
And we were about to launch.
The tests looked good.
Live experiments looked good.
Everything was fine.
And then the manager noticed
that if they searched
for Gangnam Style, and they
watched "Gangnam Style," which
is this Korean
hip-hop video that
was very popular at the time,
a suggestion in the top 10
would come up called
"Il Pulcino Pio," which
was this little Italian
musical video where
they make animal sounds.
And they were very concerned.
So the manager was
like, whoa, wait, stop.
What's going on here?
What is your machine
learning doing?
I don't know if we can trust it.
So what happened?
Well, we'll go back to that.
But let it motivate
the breakthrough
that I'm going to talk about
for the next few minutes.
And to talk about
that breakthrough,
let's ask another question,
which is, how far will you
go for hot coffee?
So you can see here, we're at
the Shoreline Amphitheater.
And how many results
should we show you
if you're looking for coffee?
How far would you
really want to go?
So let's take this example
and just build ourselves
a little machine learning
system real-time here.
And we're just going
to mock this up.
So since we're doing machine
learning, we need examples.
And we're just going
to do a 1D case here
because I draw best
in one dimension.
So let's say I show you some
coffee one kilometer away.
And you're like, yeah,
that looks great.
We show coffee a
little further away.
You're like, no, I'm not
going to go that far.
And we get a few
different examples.
And then, like our
forefathers before us,
we fit a linear line.
And we're like, great, now we
kind of know what's going on.
Except we're Google.
We have Big Data.
So we have a lot today.
We think we can do
something better.
So we fit a more
flexible model, maybe
with an SVM or a neural net.
And wow, that doesn't
look good at all, does it?
So what's gone wrong here?
Well, big data is
also noisy data.
So we have to watch out that
we don't be too flexible.
Probably the right
answer s to regularize.
So you regularize.
This still looks a
little funny, though.
Do people believe this
is really the true curve
of how far people are
willing to go for coffee?
Doesn't seem quite right to me.
So we could try to
regularize harder,
but we're going to get
back to linear pretty fast.
Let's do something else.
Let's just do a decision tree.
Still looking a
little problematic.
So again, the right
answer, well, we
fit a whole bunch
of decision trees.
We'll call it a random forest.
This will be great.
And this is trying to fit
things a little better,
but it seems a little weird
because I know something
as a human, which
is that I don't want
to walk farther for coffee.
And the machine learning
isn't picking that up.
It's like, oh, this is equal.
This is equal.
This is a little worse.
This is-- it's basically
over-fitting a little.
So what I'd really like to
see is a curve like this.
It should be smooth.
It should be
monotonically decreasing.
Should fit the data
as well as it can.
This is what we expect our
machine learning to do.
But this isn't necessarily
what machine learning
is going to do for you.
And this is just one dimension.
Imagine if we're in
100-dimensional space
or 1,000-dimensional space,
we have noisy examples,
we just can't trust that it's
going to do the right thing
just because we throw a
lot of noisy samples at it.
So what can we do?
Well, we can try to learn
monotonic functions.
It turns out that
this is hard and slow.
One of the oldest techniques,
isotonic regression,
is o of n to the
fourth complexity.
Anyone ever run an o to
the n four algorithm?
Probably not.
And it dates back a while.
This is some related work here.
The top line there
is a 1993 paper,
one of the first
papers trying to make
a neural net be monotonic.
And all these papers here
use very tiny data sets
and very few number
features because it's really
computationally challenging.
So at Google, we've developed
some new techniques for this.
And our new solution is
actually a very old solution.
And you guys might
remember these
from math class trigonometry.
You go the back
of your textbook.
And there's a table back there.
And it's a look up table.
And you're like, sine of 0.3.
And you find the closest ones.
And you interpolate.
This is from 1619 textbook.
So this is a very old idea.
So we're going to do that.
We're just going to do it
in much higher dimensions.
So here's an example
just in two dimensions.
This is a two-by-two
look-up table.
It only has four parameters.
And I'm looking at
how far I have to go
and how good the coffee is.
And I've got parameter
0, 0, 0.4, and 1.
Of course, I want
close good coffee.
And I don't want to go far
even if the coffee is good.
What's great about this
structure is that because it's
so structured, it's fast.
And because it's
so structured, I
can make it monotonic
pretty easily.
All I need to do is make
sure that my look-up table
parameters are increasing.
Then everything in between
them will also increase.
So this is easy to check and
relatively easy to constrain.
And how do we actually
learn those values?
Well, this isn't trig
class, so we're not just
going to learn sine and cosines.
We're going to learn from
examples because this
is machine learning.
So we're going to go out and get
some examples of happy people
with coffee.
And then we're going to say,
how do we fit this function,
fit these values so the look-up
table matches your examples?
And this is just like any
other function learning.
In fact, we solve it with
another structural risk
minimization just like you would
lots of other machine learning
systems.
You're going to iterate
through all your examples,
try to get the loss right.
There's some regularizer.
And what's new here is that
we have a bunch of constraints
to enforce that
monotonicity for features
that humans think
should be monotonic.
You don't have to do
it for everything,
but you're like, hey,
distance, you guys make
sure it's monotonic.
And those linear inequalities,
they don't look bad up there.
But in practice, it turns out to
be around 100,000 or maybe even
1 million of those
linear inequalities
that we need to enforce
in order to learn
really big complicated models.
So you can read more about
the details in a GMR paper
that's upcoming and in a
[INAUDIBLE] paper that's
upcoming that focuses on how we
handle all those constraints.
And you can get those papers
on Archive if you'd like.
So we can get fancier.
I showed you a
two-by-two look-up table.
We can have a much more
flexible model if we just
have a bigger look-up table.
We can grow this in dimensions.
Here's a three-dimensional
look-up table
on three features, one of which
is categorical in this case.
This look-up table structure
is going to go as two to the D.
So at some point we're going
to have some scaling problem.
But then we just start
to make ensembles.
Just like you do ensembles
of decision trees,
we can make ensembles
of look-up tables.
And we can make cascade
architectures as well.
So we can now learn incredibly
complicated, but flexible
monotonic functions if
we want, and very fast
due to that structure.
So to get back to
our story, about
to launch this machine
learning system.
And someone says,
wait, what's going on?
How do I know the
machine learning
is doing the right thing?
And the wonderful thing is we
knew the machine learning was
doing the right thing because
we forced it to be monotonic.
We're like, yeah, don't worry.
And we took a look at
the data, the features.
And the features were good, too.
It really did seem
like there was just
some set of people
that really wanted
to watch Korean hip-hop
and Italian animal sounds.
And as you may have guessed,
the answer is two-year-olds.
It turned out that these were
popular toilet-training videos
at the time.
And that this was a real issue.
OK, great.
So that's been our session
on our breakthroughs
in machine learning.
[MUSIC PLAYING]